no one needs to hack into my phone to
find out how [ __ ] up I am I put that
on the internet for free I probably
should be more concerned but honestly I
don't think I ever think about it I'm
not actively worried about people
listening to my conversations like the
government tapping into my phone but I
know that I think it was Steve Jobs
covered up the camera on his laptop but
it doesn't plagued me every day I'm in
constant fear I'm totally gonna get
[ __ ] one day but I also like someone
who watches porn on their work computer
so I guess I'm not like that concern
[Music]
Oh someone with physical access to your
phone can download spying software from
the internet onto your phone I don't
think I knew that
hence the surprise in my voice but they
have to be physically next my phone so I
have my phone in my pocket 24/7 so I'm
not too worried about that
this software gives the hacker access to
turn on your camera read your text
messages including deleted messages
listen to your phone calls and find your
location now that's scary what that's
not good I have some text that I would
prefer remain hidden it is also possible
to get hacked by accidentally
downloading malicious profiles also
known as malware it can be sent to your
phone via a link through a text message
or email or complimentary Wi-Fi access
that's [ __ ] rude I don't like win on
my computer like a pop-up will come up
and be like your computer is compromised
click here to download the thing and
then that's the thing that's gonna hurt
you like everyone's a [ __ ] lion I
mean that malware can track keystrokes a
control the hacking device including
reading and deleting emails changing
contact details and tap into phone calls
contract keystrokes damn you cannot
detect malware on your phone okay so how
many been supposed to know my phone has
an STD I always update your software
from to the latest version as soon as
you can
I never update some me I've found ways
to gain accident
without entering a passcode at all do
not click on strange links that have
been either sent to you through email or
text [ __ ] duh
do not open suspicious emails or
attachments by I know obviously if you
don't know who sent it to you don't open
it without me you grandma do not perform
sensitive activity on external public or
insecure Wi-Fi networks well I've
already [ __ ] that up because I watch
porn on our computer utilize 2-step
authentication I do put tape over your
camera yeah man I need to get the tape
on my camera ASAP I just feel like a
silly to walk around with tape but I
don't want anyone seeing me